[Music]
Rachel just hit four different states
for her hometown dates but the most
talked about one was an Aspen Colorado
where Dean confronted his father over
their strained relationship
he talked all about it with et on lines
lauren zima during their Facebook live
conversation you've admitted to not
being there it's true foot stuck in the
pan how did you feel watching last
night's episode there's a little bit of
uncomfortability involved watching I was
an emotional night it was like such an
overall moment yeah I was not very happy
with with the way that conversation
ended Dean's mom passed away when he was
just 15 Edwards his father converted to
the sixth faith Dean's uncomfortable
hometown date with Rachel was the first
time he'd seen his dad in two years we
can go right over here by the fire okay
how did you feel about the way he spoke
with Rachel I wish she would have handle
a little bit better despite telling
Rachel he was falling in love with her
the 26 year old was sent home on last
night's episode turns out that the
feelings weren't reciprocated I was pure
shock I was like going into that when I
was like oh there's no way I'm gonna go
home we first broke the news that Dean
will get another shot at finding love on
bachelor in paradise he was in Mexico
when a hookup in the pool between
Corrine and Demario led to the shutdown
of production and then he returned when
filming resumed two and a half weeks
later we got the first promo for the new
season last night which was exciting yes
yes I did
most set summer was almost ruined
lost
till it wasn't it wasn't very surprising
to see that way that they kind of
approach that but yeah I mean people
were pretty bummed that paradise was off
the air so it's nice that we're able to
get back to it
[Music]
you